hey guys how's it going today we're
going to be doing an ask IJ for those of
you that might be new here I used to do
a whole series it's called ask IJ my
screen name online is iJustine that's my
channel name it's what I've been going
by for the longest time I even have a
theme song pretty crazy I know you may
be wondering why I'm curling my kitchen
well I just shot this Thursday's cooking
video and it's baking in the oven right
now very long bake time so I said what
am I gonna do for 75 minutes I'll show
you to ask IJ so I got a bunch of
questions that I asked you guys on
Twitter and we're gonna go through and
I'm gonna answer some questions for you
if you guys want to ask me some other
questions feel free to leave them in the
comments below and legend has it if you
comment early I reply first question we
have here is from Bart and he is asking
if YouTube were to shut down what would
I do for my financial income pretty
interesting question because I started
YouTube for fun not because it was a job
or it had the potential of being a job
and now people are starting YouTube
videos as a career they're starting
YouTube channels for the sake of saying
this is going to be my job my background
is actually in graphic design and video
production and I even did like 3d and
computer programming and all kinds of
things like that which kind of led me to
where I am today
in a tech into games and making YouTube
videos so if YouTube did shut down I
don't know what I would do I do a lot of
branded and sponsored projects that you
guys do see on my channel so I might
work or start an agency but then if
YouTube's shut down then everything that
I know about YouTube and working with
brands and sponsorships probably
wouldn't really pertain any longer so
I'd probably become a dog trainer even
though the current behavior of my dog is
not very good probably something with
animals or design really I have
absolutely no idea it's in me honest
with you Alton is asking what is my
favorite Apple device that's like saying
hey mom which kids your favorite you got
a pick one really the only right answer
is my phone because the amount of things
that I do on this phone on a daily basis
it basically doesn't ever really leave
my hands so if we're going for pure time
use
I would say my phone and then maybe a
second my MacBook and really with those
two things I could be okay
the clear winner iPhone whoo hi Jay army
fan page wants to know if I got a bad
scratch on my jet black iPhone but I cry
I actually wouldn't cry over getting a
scratch on my phone because I have a
case on it so the likelihood of this
actually getting scratched in my current
state right now as my phone is not like
it's gonna happen but if I were to take
this off let's look at it so you look at
it oh baby no scratches yet oh like it
really is a very pretty device okay put
this immediately back into its case
immediately Oliver wants to know if I
have any Halloween videos planned I
actually have a week of Halloween themed
cooking videos planned for you guys I
might have mentioned this before you
guys but those should be going up next
week so I can't wait for you guys to see
them they're kind of just random sort of
along the lines at the summer snacks
nothing too crazy or wild or maybe they
do get a little crazy maybe a little
wild there were some mistakes that
happened but that usually happens can
you see this brush here actually I think
somebody asking a question about my hair
hold on let me see Kelsey says do you
straighten or blow dry your hair
straight or does it dry like that what's
your haircare styling routine stop
dragging out the shower from washing my
hair I brush it let it dry and then I
brush it again and this is really what
happens I also don't like to wash my
hair very often so I probably wash it
maybe twice a week I use a lot of dry
shampoo my favorite dry shampoo that I
use is not sponsored is from dry bar my
sister used their brunette one before
and she didn't like it because she has
darker hair so I thought hey this might
be good for you but she wasn't a big fan
of it so the one that I use is just in
like this little green canister and I
use a lot of that stuff like I'm pretty
sure I use so much that if you guys were
to breathe right now you're probably
feeling the presence of the dry shampoo
in my house although I've got a fresh
hair wash today so I'm feeling really
good June dad is asking if I'd ever make
a video with superwoman and I'm most
100% definitely would I've been in a few
of her videos before but I don't think
we've actually ever done a proper collab
so that is going to have to change I
love
she is one of the hardest-working
YouTuber women in our she's incredible I
absolutely love her so yes I definitely
would do a video with her was my
favorite thing about the hue lights my
favorite thing about hue lights is I can
control them from my phone I think I've
definitely talked about these lights
more than once on this channel I don't
want to change the current lighting
setup that I have right now because I'm
still shooting this cooking video and I
have to film the end of it here this
mystery bun in the oven is done cooking
it's not a bun at all actually that one
wants to know why I haven't been doing
as many cooking videos as I used to
usually I do cooking videos what I do do
them every Thursday if I do post them I
post them on Thursdays let the past few
weeks has been pretty much i phone
central I spend most of the week leading
up to the iPhone making videos about the
iPhone talking about iPhone accessories
and just pretty much everything
involving this sweet sweet little baby
so that's why I was in a cooking video
I'm pretty sure I just did one I think I
did donuts not too long ago do you want
this luggage yes I do I need to zoom in
on that a little apple how where did you
get that that's incredible
Brian is asking if I think that there's
actually going to be a huge earthquake I
have no idea but to be completely honest
with you over the past couple of days
I've been putting together an emergency
pack in case of any sort of emergency or
something happens I can just grab this
little suitcase it's full of things for
mady full of things for me a bunch of
survival there I went so far as getting
like a survival backpack kit that could
help
four people live up to three days I also
got this huge knife that has a fire
starter in it
thanks Bear Grylls pretty fantastic I
got all kinds of crazy things
flashlights first-aid kits just food I
got these satchels of water because I
was thinking about it you know if
something terrible did happen no matter
what it is if some sort of disaster
struck or my house fire something and I
was able to grab this pack of items I
could survive wherever I was for however
long and the dog could survive sort of
is a very important thing and it's
something that I've always wanted to put
together so having people start freaking
out about the earthquake well sort of my
catalyst to get my life together all in
one suitcase that can be just picked up
and taken if I really need it so I
definitely advise everybody to get
something together if you don't have
something or if your parents do or you
should urge them to do something as well
because I think it's pretty important to
answer
I should know I don't think anything bad
is gonna happen with the earthquake I
think sometimes people definitely
overreact and it's a high point I think
it was a 1 percent chance of North quake
happening do you want a hide everybody
cuz you look super cute right now people
say you're sick of seeing Maddie it
makes me very sad because look at his
sweet little baby face he is a sweet
prince
who's calling me Elliott is asking when
Jai becomes such a great public speaker
don't ever get nervous I wouldn't say
I'm the best public speaker but I'm
really good at talking about things in
public in situations where I'm
passionate about things or whatever that
topic is so if I'm talking about YouTube
or talking about really anything that
I'm super into or passionate it's pretty
easy I think if anybody is passionate
about something and you're thrown in
front of a crowd there will be some
sense of you know maybe being nervous
but if you love what you're talking
about and there's meaning behind it you
can do it it's really not that difficult
and most of the time there's super
bright lights so you can't actually see
the people that you're talking to so
that makes it even easier it also comes
with practice and experience so if you
were to throw me on stage maybe 10 years
ago I definitely probably wouldn't have
done as well as I did now I've been
doing it for a while so you just sort of
get better seriously though where do you
see yourself in 10 years from now making
YouTube videos are what I have no idea
if you would have told me 10 years ago
that I'd still be making youtube videos
and this would be my full-time job and
people would now be doing this it would
I don't think I'd believe you who knows
where I will be in 10 years
I mean if YouTube is still a thing that
I enjoy doing that I a hundred percent
will still be doing I hope that if you
guys are still watching my youtube
videos in 10 years then maybe I haven't
I don't even know I don't know I don't
actually know and I don't like to plan
so there's that Edmund is asking if I
prefer Instagram stories or snapchat
stories here's the honest truth as soon
as Instagram story's launched I
basically didn't use Instagram stories
or snapchat stories I would go to do
something and I would go to capture the
moment and then I just wouldn't know
which to use so at that point the moment
would be over so as far as which one I
prefer
no idea either I like snapchat for the
cool lenses and I like Instagram because
I'm already in Instagram and I'm sort of
just telling another story behind the
actual Instagram that I posted it is a
very difficult question I'd be curious
to see what you guys think
do you prefer snapchat stories or do you
like Instagram stories let me know oh
that's all the questions I have well
thank you guys for watching leave me
some questions here in this video so
that I'll actually have questions to go
back to if I decide to do another one of
these anytime soon it's always good to
get a chance to chat with you guys
because I feel like sometimes I get
super caught up in vlogging and making
cooking videos and doing tech videos
that I don't ever just sit down and sort
of back to the camera like I used to I
get to have my iPhone channel if you
guys remember that where I would just
sort of post unedited daily vlogs from
my iPhone and that was a lot of fun
because you sort of got to see the
unedited version of me which can
sometimes be a little bit terrifying
also let me know what you guys think
about doing some live streams who have a
mobile live stream option on YouTube I'm
super excited to try it so I may try
that if you guys think that would be
something that you might be into let me
know and I'll see you guys later hope
you guys have a great week a great
weekend
to choose to change what's today's
Monday oh goodness
stay tuned for this Thursday's cooking
video whatever is back here and also
been pretty much posting almost daily
videos so if I did skip a day I'm sorry
come back tomorrow they'll be a treat
for you I will see you later I'm
actually going to go because I got a
check on this thing that's in the oven
oh boy Wow
that doesn't look like what I was
thinking it was gonna look like
[Music]
hey do you think it'd be weird if we got
the drone out just to get establishing
shots today like I would just send it
right off just right up right back down
I think I like you equate and then watch
us on HTV for everyone true
you